surprised here didn't i that's right
pewdiepie here
full of surprises every single day what
is he gonna upload next
i love why what are you laugh you lose
what a meme review what this man just
keeps delivering surprises that's right
why last week i asked you leave your
entries in the subreddit in the next
episode of life
when pewdiepie is becoming gloria borger
and gloria bogar is becoming pewdiepie
wait who's that that's not gloria borger
i would know gloria borge if i saw
gloria borg and gloria borga does not
look like gloria borga
don't make me laugh is this a pigeon
is this a [ __ ] well this meme is still
kicking it apparently
you know what this place needs some more
effing glowing triangles
that's what you think you're clever
yes it is africa food
[Laughter]
yeah this meme is definitely gonna keep
coming forever
when you are fresh ripe meme and you
hear clapping in the distance
i'm in danger well i'm coming for this
this me i already had some save stop
gunnt gundt oh no we can't show that
pepsi tastes like soap what kind of
effing soap do you use
pepsi i never tried pepsi soap that
sounds good
your hands will smell like pepsi instead
of my anus no
nope yes and you haven't
f yes raised to minus one
is that inverted i don't remember math
jack said the guy shows pewdiepie how
it's done
uh excuse me this is how you handshake
everyone knows that
okay this is wrong this is right
get it right please i'm not doing it
wrong everyone else is
thank you
suspect is playing on foot hey look it's
grande reposted by someone else
suspect is acting extremely erratic [ __ ]
you
[Laughter]
do you have any idea hey i am
i'm fast as [ __ ] i should have seen that
coming
the tides have changed oh my god
that is so creative you never know what
memes are gonna go next
who exactly is pewdiepie and why is he
copying me
what what i'm calling you out gloria
fake
borger that's right that's what you are
a faker
a faker daker don't make me angry i will
diss track you
i will fight you in the arena woman to
woman let's
battle when somebody says all pewdiepie
videos are the same
gloria bogg she works extremely
hard guys i can't believe the
discrimination just because
she's a woman sorry i'm very
invested in the social politic issues of
sexism
can we copy strike pewdiepie for our
little life submissions
what no no you can this is my original
content
please if you can't respect me gloria
is not going to be happy and you don't
want that
do you if this image gets
2 likes i would literally drink water
absolute mess
you guys are drinking water a butt
running off
god damn it a bot running around
aimlessly
in pubg mobile is this a real player
excuse me this is because i uploaded the
pub g mobile video game
and i was killing it everyone was super
impressed
but you're not you're just playing
against bots no they're not
they are legitimate players i am just so
good
stop killing everybody a man in florida
woke with a headache only to discover
his wife had shot him while he slept
he survived restoration hundred
wow your move youtube youtube
demonetized
pewds this is a sponsored video
it has come to this i just have to play
online sex games
for revenue these days you know it could
be worse actually
i'm living the dream
what
[Music]
oh that's great i just wanted a mac
chicken man
why is gloria borger acting like she's
the one who got
copy strike
[Music]
that's weird that's really strange he
must be thinking
about other women will pewdiepie ever
stream pubg again
well finally i have decent internet now
look i can actually stream now so maybe
i will
i posted my internet speed on twitter
literally everyone is like
that's what you sound like that's what i
hear that's all i get
gloria borges wikipedia page
she also appears on pure news network
occasionally
diversifying your content gloria borge
did it right
what the squad fam loves that's right i
don't understand
how anyone could possibly think to call
alinity
a twitch thought it really makes me
angry
i'm glad you guys are so respectful in
the comments as well really nice to see
a wonderful
wonderful community that treats women
with respect
let's copy strike all of lawyer for our
submissions if pewdiepie doesn't give us
bonus
no you can't do that
i will copy strike you back seriously
don't
i'm i'm serious i'm currently in uganda
and just found
this painted on the wall of a school he
finally found the way
wonderful congratulations knuckles
this is so happy can we copy strike
people
yeah yeah it's not like i haven't seen
this meme a million times
hard to swallow bills
bonus meme is dead because we turned
bonus meme
to me well
well well well you finally figured it
out
but pewdiepie didn't review it hmm
maybe i will don't test me
so brad won you said if we hit 600 000
likes bonus meme would be back
yes this is true but the video got copy
striked
right so it got completely nullified i
am so sorry
we are now entering the last page of the
memes where the goodest of the goods
are hiding pure news introduces the mean
that will become the victim
your life you lose going to have fun
with the meme until satisfied
why fans will use the mean for in
slavery
meme review meme execution wow
wow you think you're so woke huh you
finally figured it out huh
it doesn't change anything i'm gonna
keep making this forever
i finally figured out the youtube
formula
with no effort dude's got class what can
i say
i'm a man of culture i didn't even know
there was a real gloria burger there is
one real gloria boga
and no one else stop getting confused
it's not that hard
the bridge where bad things happen
well now i can technically stream pubg
again everyone just thought i got banned
i just couldn't be bothered
so who knows the return of solid ass
make a meme so people can see it make a
meme
so pewdiepie can see it make a meme to
get into hawaii
make a meme to get into the y so later
you can copy strike the video
for all the revenue i mean it's not a
terrible business plan
it's basically what collab is doing
anyway
collab drm are just sitting there like
gosh we need a good meme
how can we infiltrate the system upvote
if you want pewds to tell us why he's in
another room
guys sometimes i like to record in the
closet there's nothing wrong with that
stop discriminate being swedish being
swedish speaking english
being swedish speaking english visiting
japan being swedish speaking english
vision in japan marrying
italian being swedish speaking english
vision ninja primary natalia selling
russian merch check it out everybody
lincoln we don't sell them anymore i got
new ones coming though they look
hella lit guys my daughter loves to
sleep with her bun in the air and it's
the cutest thing i thought she was in a
microwave
i've seen this pathetic when pewds
is playing pubg and he heads towards
the bridge bad things happen around
bridges
oh it's just a meme
i love this fan art really cool skull
dino i don't know if he's the one that
posted it
gotta investigate oh it is super dope
thank you very much
and the last one is an animation all
right that's cool
is that my closet
[Applause]
why you couldn't just sample me saying
it
[Applause]
we need to fight back right now
what do you got oh no
damage my only weakness
this meme is a
zero
[Music]
oh no i feel like any time i rate a meme
zero it gets popular anyway
amazing to be continued wow
where is the story going to go next who
knows
an amazing episode of why thank you guys
i mean you're welcome for being able to
support yourself by submitting memes you
are welcome that's right leave a like if
you have a pulse
thank you guys for watching and as
always
bye